that's life. Develop time where one year, they're the cells in the human body that are never renewed.
However, their ramifications or branches keep on growing. Do you know that a hundred thousand
neurons were pinhead? And the number of their possible combinations could contain several
thousand digits. Hard to imagine, isn't it? What is the function of these billions of neurons?
It's to perceive the outside world and get us to grasp it. To regulate, harmonize, and coordinate
the perfect functioning of our inside world.
The world of the human body.
It's all very complicated, my friends.
So let's take a closer look.
Here we are, inside a nerve cell at work.
Well, what news of the outside world?
Message.
News of the world outside?
Not very much, really.
We don't like the dust and we're breathing heavily,
but it's nothing important.
Tired.
Hot?
Oh, dear.
Transmit.
So what information do we have?
77 informs us that it doesn't like dust.
Which we do, Chief.
Shall we react?
Transmit that it's quite bearable, he'll have to make do with it.
And now 8033 is a little out of breath, Chief.
That's too bad. It's normal when you run.
Excuse me, excuse me, I don't agree at all.
Information from the throat is that it's completely dry.
How long's this discussion going on?
The skin on the feet tells me that the shoelaces are too tight on the foot.
It must just forget about it.
The skin on my feet is itching to go.
I require some saliva for the throat.
A little cough would clear it.
No, I don't think that'll be of any help.
think it'll help? At this rate we'll get nowhere. Tell her she must slow down. She'll have to swallow,
that's all. If these youngsters can't look out for themselves, we can't be held responsible. Remember,
you're not here to criticize, you're here to coordinate. You wouldn't say they were in
desperate rush, would you? And then we speedies have to make up for the last time. Listen! What?
The cell continuously receives about 30,000 pieces of information that it has to deal with,
And this way, you'll never sort it out.
Now, you suggested a little cough.
Let's take a vote.
Those in favor of a cough win.
And in addition, I think the heart should beat faster.
I believe that's the way to proceed.
Let's vote again and see how many are in favor of my proposition.
Ah, yes, I have the majority.
Order reflex, coughing, and acceleration of the heartbeat immediately.
Thank you.
And not a moment too soon, Maestro.
The problem having been resolved, I would like you to note that right here,
Between the incoming and outgoing information, we should be able to find all the knowledge, all the memories, and all the sensitivity that we, together with the brain, have always used.
Gentlemen, surely no one will deny this.
Information flows swiftly from one cell to another, carried by our speedy runners.
Uh-oh.
I suppose you do know which way to go, don't you?
No problem.
I go straight to the sympathetic, and they will have to figure it out.
Figure what out?
How to get the message.
Message?
To the heart.
And you, do you know where you're going?
Yes, I do.
Silly question. Of course I know where I'm going.
Silly question indeed.
Okay, Mr. Nowell, I've still something to tell you.
You're in luck.
The cough is a reflex, so you take the shortcut, see?
The shortcut? The shortcut?
Well, didn't they teach you that?
Coughing is a reflex, so you're entitled to go straight to the command centres bypassing the brain.
Right at the intersection through the reflex arch.
The reflex arch? Of course! How could I have forgotten?
You're impossible, you youngsters of today.
All you want to do is to rush around in a frenzy.
What is the point of rushing if you're not sure where you're going?
There they all were on top of me, in front of me, at the side of me.
Up there, down there, surrounded me, enveloped me and squashed me flat.
Pass on the relay.
Get your man into position to intercept him.
Draw muscles for a cough.
Hurry, off you go.
And I was quite quick.
Seconds since the time.
Pretty good time.
Pushing, please.
Don't forget that each one of you is a unique key that fits into only one corresponding lock.
That fits into a corresponding lock.
Like that.
I'm due a lot waiting for me.
Well, the information will have to get through.
Message must use the reflex road, and I happen to be going that way.
Reflex!
I'm late. Always last to leave, but always first to arrive. That's the way I am, sir.
Do you know where you're going?
I know the way. Shortcut along reflex road, and straight to the spinal column.
Impulse to intercostal muzzles.
Only accepting ascetic collides. Nobody else. Order to intercept all intruders.
No, no, not you. Go that way, please. That way.
Let me through. I do my work just as well as anybody.
It's about to be transmitted to intercostal muscles.
They're received and transmitted.
There's so much to carry today.
But somehow, I just don't feel up to it today.
These are oxygen bubbles we're carrying, right?
So why can't I breathe properly?
Yes, I can see there's fatigue.
They should have reacted up there. I just don't understand it.
What can they be doing?
I'm going to have to take a decision, gentlemen.
What's going on here? What went wrong?
Eh?
Thank you, Maestro. Running is very tiring.
We're going to have to send more oxygen.
Yes, of course, and we must speed up the heart and the respiration.
But surely those orders have been sent, haven't they?
Yes.
Yes, Maestro.
Then for goodness sake, find out where there's a delay.
Pass through here.
But I have a message for the heart with me.
Nevertheless, you've no right to pass through here.
The heart has its own nervous system, and your message must go along the sympathetic passage.
This arguing at once, please, and go straight to the spinal column.
Thoracic level, understood.
Centres, fire the Aesthetic system.
Accelerate the heartbeat and increase the pulse rate from 95 to 110 per minute.
Execute at once.
Bordelers, get moving.
Hurry, hurry, hurry, hurry.
Vehicles, keep to your own lane.
You're quite right. That's the rule of the road.
Don't you go that far. It's urgent.
Tebbia is a very sensitive area, but too much pain is useless.
Let's calm him down a bit.
Once again, trying to prevent us from doing our job properly.
This is true.
We've also got our rights. We ride us.
You must slow down on Delta Road.
There's a traffic jam in the tunnel.
It's good to sit down for a little while.
Yes, it's good to sit down for a little while.
Yes, I agree.
Now, I have something to tell you that might come as quite a surprise.
But we race through the body at the speed of a Formula One meteor.
And I mean to say, just look at the size of us.
Just think, most of our errands only take one hundredth of a second.
Pretty good, isn't it?
So a little bit of a rest isn't a bad idea.
No, no, can't rest now, straight back to work.
Rest isn't necessarily good for everyone.
Yes, the nervous system, you know, never rests.
There's always some task to perform.
To feel, to see, to hear.
In fact, to perceive the world outside and analyze the information received.
And then, of course, to make the body react in its own best interest.
Or in the most intelligent way possible.
Just look over there.
One in front is correct.
Demonstrate to you that one can do much better.
One can do that.
Well, we can all make mistakes.
And after space, shuttle's a solar belt.
And that's by no means all that we can create.
But this, or this?
Neurons of the brain, command center of our behavior and our feelings, certainly.
Dreams, sentiment, creativity, personality, all that can only be the product of some chemistry.
Of the combustion of these neurons of glucose and amino acids.
Quite a thought.
Extraordinary, isn't it, what the brain and the neurons can do?
So, since you have a brain, try to use it the best way you can, at all times.
But keep thinking, my friends, keep thinking, thinking.